les flamands de dans ce sens rien dire
sans rien dire au dimanche soutenant les
flamandes dans ce sens rien dire
les flamands de ce n'est pas qu'au sens
si elle danse c'est parce qu'elles ont
vingt ans et que 20 ans il faut se
fiancer se fiancer vont pouvoir se
marier et se marier avoir des enfants
c'est ce que leurs envies leurs parents
le bedeau mêmes sources l'archiprêtre
qui prêchent couvent et c'est pour ça
c'est pour sa cadence des flamands le
monde voit le monde les flamandes dans
ce sens fort et mis son frémir ou
dimanche selon les flamands dans ce sens
frémir les flamands de ce n'est pas vrai
me sens si elle danse c'est parce
qu'elles ont 30 ans et quatre en temps
il est bon de montrer que tout va bien
que poussent les enfants et le houblon
élevé dans le prix elles font la fierté
de leurs parents et du bedeau son
imminence l'archiprêtre qui prêchent
souvent et je pense à c'est pour ça que
la danse mais flamande les flamandes
mais pas les bâtiments
le manque de temps s'en sort sans
sourire au dimanche ça n'en les flamands
de dans ce sens sont les flammes hors
tout ça n'est pas souriant si l on sait
qu'elles ont 70 ans que celle qu'entend
il est bon de montrer que tout va bien
qu'on a toujours bon pied et donc blond
est comblée d'entrée toute vêtue de noir
comme leurs parents comme le dos et
comme de son imminence l'archiprêtre qui
va d'autocollants elle mérite et c'est
pour sa cadence mais flamande les
flamandes les flammes et pas les femmes
mais sans mollir samedi à dimanche sans
les flamandes dans ce centre malien mais
vraiment ce n'est pas comme ça c'est
parce que l'on chante en cash
oui mais bon de montrer que tout va bien
qu'on a toujours bon pied et bon blanc
et bombes les d'entre elles ont retrouvé
leurs parents et le dos et même son
imminence l'archiprêtre qui repousse au
courant et c'est pour ça qu'une dernière
fois dense mais flamande et flamande
l'évadé
flamande
[Musique]